Linda is in Los Angeles hi Linda welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank you so
much for taking my call
sure how can I help ya I am a music
artist and I also need to finish and
release an upcoming album
I have roughly $8,000 left in student
debt with all that daring great about an
average of 5% and then I also have stock
about ten thousand dollars worth of
stock so I can sell immediately what's
it like to finish the album probably
probably I think it's so complicated
it's like you have to do the album and
then you have to make music videos I
would say roughly another $1,000 $1,000
yeah okay and are you amazing is your
full-time job music artist is that what
you do for a living not yet okay cool
what are you doing for a living what do
you make I work part-time in retail and
I'm also looking for like a full-time
job to bring in more income how are you
living part-time retailers oh yeah I
know I actually almost gone through my
savings okay so this is your first
project then it's actually not my first
project okay
did you make money on the other one I
have to varying degrees not much because
you don't have our money yes that's
right okay where's the stock come from
I use my student loan they gave me a
grant and this is when the market was
down so I used that money to buy some
stocks and you know when stocks were
down and I still have them okay all
right and okay so the biggest issue I
hear in my conversation with you is not
the debt and not your music project both
of those things can be
handled because we can cash out the
stock and pay off the debt and you got a
thousand dollars for your music projects
how much is in your savings I've gone
through my savings know I get what I
thought right now okay so then so the
biggest issue I'm coming back to the
scaring me and my conversation is your
income right because you're gonna end up
abandoning your music project and not
being able to give it any time if you're
homeless right so I mean we really have
to get you a career going you have a car
right I do have a car okay cool
how old are you I'm in my late thirties
okay cool all right so what are you
gonna do to start making several
thousand dollars a month immediately
because you needed that yesterday you
know question I feel like I've been
barking up so many different trees
pitching music and pitching the music
stuff yeah that's really interesting
yeah oh I got that that's your passion
also get that you're starving to death
and you're about to starve out of your
passion I'm your biggest hero biggest
your biggest fan I want you to take your
music career and make all you can make
out of it but until you monetize it you
are gonna do what music people have done
for generations and that's work on a
side job nice you're starving to death
right I mean next month you're out of
money right you know what yeah no I
understand yeah okay all right
it's up to you gravity yeah I'm sorry to
be mean I'm not mean to you I'm just
scared for you I want you to win here
and I because if you don't address you
you get there's two sides of this
equation there's the outgo side in a
situation like this the financial people
like me we call it the burn rate okay
you your burn rate was what it costs you
to live versus how much savings you had
and we know I wish you had done the math
four months ago and realized your burn
rate was going to have you broke today
so four months ago you'd started earning
an income you still had a little bit of
that savings laying around that would
put you in a much more comfortable place
because a desperate artist usually ends
up being a broke artist and I don't want
you to be that I want you to win I'm in
Nashville I mean you know how we get the
next country music stars attention a
waiter right I mean this is how people
do this all the time and a bunch of
big-time Nashville hacks or friends of
mine and almost all of those people had
a serious side hustle till they started
actually monetizing their music career
and they didn't necessarily have a major
career they didn't go become a medical
doctor or something like that or an
accountant and shut down all of their
passion but they had to have eating
money with the side hustle the hustle
and grind and and you don't have enough
of that coming right now if you get that
part solved I would just cash out the
stock to answer your original question
and pay off your loans and you've got
the extra two thousand dollars to finish
your your project that you're working on
but then there's no money to eat with
next month so if you solve that part
then that's what I would do with this
stock money until you solve that part I
would let that stock sit there because
it might be the difference in you and
eating right now until we get this
solved hey thanks for the call